good morning Hank it's Tuesday yesterday
I saw this on my tumblr dashboard and
immediately knew that something was very
wrong
it turns out there were coordinated
attacks near the finish line of the
Boston Marathon killing at least two
people and injuring more than a hundred
I don't really know what to say about
any of it Hank I mean to call this
attack cowardly is an insult to cowards
so I guess I'm recording this by the way
I'm on my way to the dentist and yes I
know that my seat belt is not buckled
but to be fair I am in a parking lot
anyway we don't currently know who was
responsible for what happened at the
marathon but if you look at the videos
and by now I assume that most of us have
you see two extraordinary things first
you see all these flags along the race
route all these representations of
nationalism I mean the flag is the thing
that you turn to when you sing your
national anthem it's the thing that you
pledge allegiance to it's a symbol of
you being part of a particular US the
Zambian US the Norwegian US the American
US and by extension all the people who
aren't American or Norwegian or Zambian
are part of them but in the videos from
the marathon bombings you see all these
flags lined up together none higher than
any other those 96 flags representing
the nations of people running the Boston
Marathon are side by side because they
stand for a larger us and us sharing a
human endeavor that doesn't require of
them and the flags aren't blown over by
the explosion but within seconds some of
those flags do come down they come down
when people on lookers volunteers first
responders tear down the barricades to
get to the injured look for the helpers
the great mr. Rogers said about
tragedies you will always find people
who are helping and we do Hank there
were coordinated attacks in Iraq
yesterday that killed dozens of people
and there were helpers there was a
tremendous earthquake at the
iran-pakistan border this morning and
there are helpers I think I'm cool with
living in a world with flags but I'm
most proud to live in a world that can
hold events where no flag flies above
any other there are people who don't
want to live in that world Hank but I
know that we are not going to give it up
and I know that we can always look in
hope to the helpers and endeavor to be
among them Hank I will see you on Friday